التطورات الميدانيه لحرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا قالت السلطات والمواليه لروسيا
في مقاطعه دونيتس كان ثلاثه مدنيين جرحوا
في قصف القوات الاوكرانيه على مدينه
ومقاطعه
الى ان القوات الاوكرانيه
بنحو 70 قذيفه ما الحق اضرارا ماديه بعدد
من المباني السكنيه ومرافق البنيه التحتيه
المدنيه
في المقابل قال قائد القوات البريه
الاوكرانيه
ان قوات الدفاع الجوي تنفذ عمليات قتاليه
في بخموت ضد طائرات روسيه مسيره واظهر
فيديو للدفاعات الاوكرانيه استهداف مسيرات
روسيه من طراز اورلان وبسيارتين من طراز
ازاله واكدت القياده الاوكرانيه استمرار
دفاعها عن بخمه انها احدثت خسائر كبيره
بالقوه الروسيه شرق ضخمه حسب وصفها
وبدورها فدت الاداره العسكريه في خاركيد
ان خمسه اشخاص اصيبوا في قص روسيا استهدف
مقاطعه خاركيب شمال شرقي اوكرانيا وذكرت
الاداره في بيان لها ان القصف تنبا بتسعه
صواريخ من طراز اس 300 وادى لتضرر منشاه
ببنيه تحتيه مدنيه ومبان سكنيه خاصه كما
هاجمت القوه الروسيه مرافق البنيه التحتيه
الحيويه في منطقه ايزيون جنوب شرقي
المقاطعه بطائرات مسيره